let's go on this and then check this
[ __ ] apostles
I'll look at that hallway so creepy huh
what did i do I just walked into [ __ ]
always thank you game
[Music]
I'll come on whole way of doing my
parenting Jesus okay so I'm out of ideas
where the songs like it's from there
it's like if there's another in this
class
but I saw a lever somewhere so maybe we
can use that
these whole six come on that makes no
sense
I don't want to carry on stupid game
where am i anyway
like I forgot something
but I'm not sure though
can you tell me about for gotten maybe
are I can't describe my anymore
this it should be nearby all right let's
find it then I thought I saw one here
like all right
wait so there was a puzzle too actually
well whatever
where my ball is isn't working properly
let's go let's go let's go yeah MLG go
bro
where where
this is so much fun I saw the puzzle Oh
[Music]
hello
now there's nothing sweet
go no problemo
[Music]
ah look at this being [ __ ] works
sometimes the [ __ ]
that's no more right
and then do this one
yeah whoa
okay it's safe there let's close the
door after us I don't want and what's
sneaking up on me
nothing here
I think they hear their whatever Oh
oh come on
oh that looks bad it's really bad let's
go then
but we do it for science science I tell
you cyanide sign tight sign right so
dark it's so hard oh it's so dark it's
getting darker how can it even be
possible to get dark
oh it's water its water
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah I know okay I got this no
problem
what the [ __ ] was that we need the
science type quick
I get the boat alright let's go down
here that
ok so I got the hammer I got the hammer
towards fricking hammer
look at that current it's so strong
oh whatever actually I'm not over at all
it's no problem
oh look at me so cozy here what's up in
this place
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
what
suck with that thing am I stuck here or
what if I jump
wow that was really
uneasy I guess
what are you stammer though
here
where do you stop her
stop being so cold Daniel
corazon
any momento yay go back up I guess it's
better than down there
not sure what you do with the hammer
though unless it's hammer time I guess
but I don't think is this hammer time
[Music]
okay so let's go back I guess not sure
that's a good idea or not but like I
missed something in the dining hall
I could imagine the holes were filled
with families and children got around
the table sound here though that's
probably this is stupid sure I mean it's
there same thing almost if you think
about it
booty I've been looking everywhere for
you
now don't call me I just it's not really
look here that
sweet sweet oh I can't oh okay
use it on the lock right made sense
intense feeling of being watched I
already read that so I thought waited
again
I'm hungry
am I going so lit up here okay Ola doula
Dolph can't get along a blonde and pull
it down though oh all right
[Music]
nothing in here
hmm
if I'm supposed to cook some food let's
take the other way I guess after [ __ ]
master doesn't care
not scary not scary
come on this stair is so annoying oh
hello
let's hear I can move I'm so sorry kelis
okay nothing really
alright you're going down where you
bearing oh that was a puzzle I knew that
I knew then totally oh okay I know what
I did know the barrel that was up in the
thingy fell down and I can solve puzzle
without even knowing it okay that's how
I roll
if you didn't notice kissing you well
penis ah [ __ ] what do I hate was he even
coming here I was just down there but
[Music]
you